واحد مختلف هو أيضا عالمي
الحليب أو اللعب الافتراضي فان دير الناس
إنه يرقص لفترة أطول
ليس من الجيد جدًا أن تكون قادرًا على القيام بالحقيقة
الرياضة في الهواء الطلق عدة أيام في
الحبس جيد جدا ونحن كذلك
سعيد جدا أن أكون حولها
حامل البحر العام الذي هو نهرك
طرح المزيد من الكومة ومن ابنة
إيمانك الشخصي
تلفزيون الهاتف الذكي هذا متحرك
وهذا أيضًا في أفضل حالاته
الحياة إذا وضع العامل في لحظة
مشدود إلى tvn نفس هاتا من أنيمي
في حياتك المهنية كان ذلك نتيجة للحلفاء
لقد تغيرنا للقفز من أجل أمريكا
الطريق والعالم أو أي شيء
نعم حسنا مربكة بعض الشيء لأنني كان
فهمت أنه حتى الساعة 8 مساء
هل يمكن أن تأتي إلى الشاطئ
بهدوء أراه وصلت إلى هنا كان هناك
عدد قليل من الناس، وكان هناك سوء فهم
لقد كانت مجرد نزهة إذا كانت المعلومات مفقودة
لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أن هناك مرونة
من قبل الشرطة
إيجابية ولذا نحن على مسافة
نحن مع الأشخاص الذين نعيش معهم
لا يوجد
هذا العام يجلس مع المنطقة
بعد المباراة ما يلزم القيام به
وظيفة من خيمينيز الشرق الأكثر تنوعا
أعطاه برشلونة الخاص بك
هذه القطرات هي التي كان علينا أن
جعل سهل الصحة